hour local police were very busy over
the holiday weekend
there was a streak of deadly violence
across the valley bianca holmen live
this morning with details on all these
cases bianca good morning to you
good morning john police are
investigating six
different situations that happen from
saturday to monday it is definitely a
sign that there was an increase in
violence over the holiday weekend
so here's what we know that happened
over the weekend on sunday
north las vegas police say seven people
were injured in a shootout that left two
men dead
and prior to that three others were
killed on saturday in separate incidents
and yesterday another man was shot to
death in the northeast part of the
valley
people we talked to say they feel the
holiday weekend combined with lifting of
covet restrictions led to deadly
confrontations
i think the pandemic restrictions being
lighter than the past few months might
have something to do with it people were
cooped up so long and now they're
getting out and getting crazy because of
the holiday
maybe more people more drinking
police said none of these incidents
appear to be random acts of violence
and of course the violence that happened
in las vegas wasn't just
particular and unique to our city there
is a group
that is called the national group is
called gun violence
archive reports at least 150 people they
were killed in about
400 shootings across the country over
the holiday weekend
back to you guys in the studio